[Music]
dana is with us in new york city hi dana
how are you
hi dave and christina thank you for
taking my phone call and thank you for
changing my family tree sure what's
up i have two questions for you today if
that's okay sure
okay um my husband and i are receiving
an inheritance check in the amount of
three hundred thousand dollars and we
disagree on how to best spend it for our
future
um a little bit about us we're 32 we're
on baby step six with no children yet we
have um 286 000 left to pay on our home
and our home is valued at 459.
um my husband would like to invest the
money in the market in a large cap fund
but i would like to pay off the mortgage
with that money what would be your
recommendation
well apparently you're on baby step six
but he's not
right
yes
yeah
so um
because i mean
it's a trick question you already knew
the answer
he insisted i call so i'm calling okay
to confirm yeah so the concern is not
that the money came from an inheritance
the concern is that you guys are not an
agreement on what to do with money which
means you're not aligned on whether
you're working our system or anybody's
system
okay because if you're working our
system the answer is already uh it's a
foregone conclusion you're gonna pay the
house off
yes yeah it hasn't there's never been a
time in the baby step history of doing
this for 30 years that i told somebody
to oh no let's put money in mutual funds
instead of paying off the house
never one time have i ever said that
anywhere anytime in the history of my
life
correct
you knew what i was going to say
so you i mean you tricked your husband
if you if if i became the
if i became the arbitrator of this then
you tricked your husband because you
knew what the answer was
well he wanted to put it into the market
because he was running a 30-year
projection on it and he thought that it
might be a better long-term investment
than paying off the mortgage but
we're following the baby steps so
okay
well then do we need to discuss for a
minute why the baby steps work better
than his plan
i think it would be great for him to
hear okay all right because i'm a nerd
like him so it took me a while to get
there number one i started with the idea
that i don't borrow money because the
bible says the borrower's slave to the
lender i started from a faith
perspective
later on i'm a math nerd and i i had to
dig into the math i had to figure it out
not because i wanted to play god but
because i really knew that god was
smarter than me and i was just trying to
figure out what he was saying so here's
the thing when your husband says i'm
going to put money in a large cap fund
he's looking at a 10 to 12 percent rate
of return on a good large cap
okay
and he's thinking okay instead of paying
off my three or four percent mortgage i
can make 10 12 percent so i'm making a
spread here on that money
and and he and then he ran a spreadsheet
out based on that which is what i would
have done because i'm a classic nerd
like he is
you know if that worked
then why would we ever pay off the house
well what you left out of that formula
and what i left out of that formula in
my early days what he's leaving out of
the formula now too
is risk
and 100
of the foreclosures occur on a home with
a mortgage
when you're walking around without a
mortgage your risk has gone down and to
mathematically not include risk
in your math formula means your math
formula is incomplete
and no one does that in this discussion
until
i kind of came up with it so
uh you know if you're doing a
sophisticated analysis on a company and
you're buying stock in that company
one of the things you would do is is you
would become concerned if the company
had too much debt
because that stock then is riskier debt
equals risk and you would discount the
price of the stock if you're doing a
sophisticated analysis based on the
the the level of bonds they're carrying
and other debt instruments that they're
carrying so the more in debt the company
is the more likely it is to fail
everyone will say yes we all agree to
that and so debt equals risk and debt
equals risk here now is it manageable
risk yeah but so so it's a small
backache
it's manageable but your back still
hurts
and so you know that that that's what
we're dealing with here so the end of
the story is that when you don't have
any debt you end up making better
decisions relationally
medically your physical health is better
you're more likely to have a higher
quality and lasting marriage your
children are more functional because
there's not any weight on your shoulders
tense between your shoulder blades when
you get home at night
everything changes and when you quantify
all that math up it'll kick that little
mutual fund's butt
because you lowered the risk and you set
down the 300 pound weight that you got
used to carrying and all of society
carries it and so they think you're
strange for even having this discussion
yeah it's quote unquote normal
but dana we're really sorry for your
loss too it's not a fun way to get your
house paid off through an inheritance
because obviously that means you must
have lost someone but i do hope that in
paying off the house it'll be a good way
to honor them being able to be debt free
and free of any payments that'll be a
really wonderful way to bring honor to
that money yeah
and i i do want you guys to go back and
address the idea that somehow dana you
got on the baby steps and he didn't
because that's going to be important
going forward that you are aligned
on money and what we're going to do with
it so i'll give you an example dana now
that we got our house paid off many many
many many years ago sharon and i did and
so you know how do we have to become
aligned about money well one of the
things we did was
um we laid out a
uh a percentage
calculation
to every dollar of money that we now get
because i'll get a big check from a
publisher or a big check from this or a
big check from that and if i don't
already have that aligned with my wife
where that's going then i have to redo
that every time and that burns a lot of
calories
in the relationship yeah and so we have
a simple system a certain percentage of
every check we get now
goes we we're christians
evangelical christians so we tithe 10
i'll go and tell you what part of it is
we set aside 40 because the government
takes that because we make a lot of
money we're evil we're rich we must be
punished
and so
40 goes to them 10 to the church now i
got 50 left over that 50 i'm not going
to tell you what it is but it's broken
between three categories
increased lifestyle which is a very
small percentage of that increased
investing and increased generosity
beyond the tithe
and so every time i get a check in
i can apply that formula to it because
sharon and i are aligned on our system
and i don't even have to think about it
shouldn't i think about it and so we got
some money in the fun account over here
and i say hey let's get you a different
car that'll be fun and she goes she
doesn't have to go oh where'd that come
from are we investing enough or are we
generous enough
it's all set it's all done we'll have to
have the discussion again because we are
in alignment
and dana that's what i want for you more
than i want your house paid off even
because that going forward you guys
being in agreement on principle of what
you're going to do how you're going to
do things is
that and so
you know other principles we use we do
not give to or invest in anything unless
we're both in agreement and have peace
about it that's good
when in doubt don't
i've got a funny feeling about him
then don't donate to his ministry or
don't invest in his thing
or her thing you know because every time
she has a feeling it costs me a lot of
money if i go against it because she her
feelings are always right driving me
nuts
but um
you know that's the thing so that that's
what i want for you dana i want that
kind of alignment to where
we don't have to
and you know you know if we get money in
from wherever it comes inheritance bonus
check sale of something
what are we gonna do with it this is
what we're gonna do yeah and i love that
you all have a system too that makes it
so
simple it takes a lot of the stress off
of everyday decisions you don't have to
revisit it every time right
right automatic
and so and then it gets it releases you
because sharon's a freaking tight wad i
mean she it's hard for her to enjoy
money not hard for me i'm a spender like
rachel but
um but the but but
you know if it once she knows it went in
that
lifestyle bucket
then she'll go buy you know another
stupid thing for the house or something
that she wants and not feel guilty about
it right that's great yeah because it
comes out of the stupid house bucket you
know that kind of thing right yeah but
you gotta have buckets for this stuff
that you're in alignment and then i'm
not mad that she went and bought
something for a stupid house because
we're in alignment on it
just like it's like being in alignment
on the budget it's the same thing
so dana that's what you guys got to do
you need to get your philosophies a
little bit more lined up
and
we don't borrow money and we don't
invest money
while we got debt on the house this is
the ramsey show